alright it looks like we're now live
with this next hangout the philosophy
pop up series this month as I think
everybody should know it is stoic we can
stay awake on and stoic on axes so you
know I had to do something on stoicism
so I put a pole up for my patreon
supporters and and then open it up to
other people to see what what they
wanted me to talk about and stoicism and
emotions got pretty close to winning but
stoicism and the dichotomy have control
a perennial issue always being talked
about came up and one instead so I'm
actually gonna put a little pitch here
about my patreon supporters and if
you're interested in contributing to
that so what I thought I would do today
is talk a little bit about the dichotomy
of control and it's it's something that
we see mostly coming out of epictetus
attacks I'll tell you exactly where in
just a moment I'm just doing a few
linking things right now very quickly so
I can have everything set up as we we
want it I got to get into the things I
can actually see or your comments and I
gotta get into that live control thing
so while I'm waiting on that while I'm
figuring out how to get myself back to
that control room and see the comments
that you've got let's talk about the
dichotomy of control it's very
straightforward it's talking about the
things that are in our control or in our
power or if you want another translation
of it our business those things that are
up to us at home own in the Greek and
those things that that are not those
things that are outside of our control
that that has to do with other people
that you know you can say other people
fate prophecies all these
two things an epictetus tells us about
us tells us about this in enchiridion
chapter 1 and in the very first chapter
of the very first book of the discourses
which is entitled those things that are
in our control I think a lot of people
only look at enchiridion 1 and so they
end up getting a somewhat distorted
picture of what's going on so what you
want to do is you you actually want to
look at these references to what's in
our control what's not in our control
throughout the rest of the enchiridion
but also in Epictetus discourses and in
in other places too and you know the
other Stoics don't talk quite so much
about this they they talk about other
related things but i think you can read
it in to seneca or read it into marcus
aurelius or or other people as well so
let's start by talking about what he
thinks is actually in our control so if
you've read uncrating 1 you know that he
says that what's in our control are our
desires and aversions our opinions or
judgments and our choices or sometimes
it's translated impulse [ __ ] may in in
greek and then a little bit later in in
that he's going to talk about other
things that are also within the scope of
our control as well but what's not in
our control this is what throws a lot of
people this is I think what what led
somebody like William Irvine in his book
on stoicism you know a guide to the
happy life to try to substitute a
trichotomy of control I know this is a
very controversial topic that many
people get very worked up about myself I
I don't think that there's anything
really intrinsically bad about you know
positing a tricot I mean it just turns
out that I think that the trichotomy is
already dealt with the way that Ervin is
articulating it dealt with adequately in
epictetus in his work so Epictetus says
that our body is not something that is
in our control that's a bit paradoxical
right and we'll talk about why in just a
moment
he says you know wealth property
finances those sorts of things are not
in our control he says that reputation
Doakes you know that's not in our
control powers you know being assigned
positions of responsibility that's not
in our control and there's a lot of
other things that he'll talk about as
well in enchiridion one the main upshot
of that is is to tell us look if you
can't make this distinction between
what's really in your control and what
you might think is in your control but
isn't in your control you're gonna be
unhappy if you concentrate on the things
that really are up to you that really
are your business you're going to be a
much happier freer tranquil person if
you're if you're tying yourself in if as
we say you emotionally invest yourself
in these other things that aren't really
in our control like what other people
think or how our body you know looks day
after day or you know how much money
we've got in our accounts and what we
can buy with it or whether we get the
promotion at work or not if that's where
you you know to use a non epic tedium
phrase but that's where you place your
treasure you're laying yourself in for a
lot of heartache because it might go all
right for a little while but then pretty
soon you're gonna run into obstacles and
you're gonna be to use a favorite word
of his hindered you can't be hindered in
the things that really are yours but you
can be hindered in things that belong to
somebody else or to you might say the
universe or to random process these are
things like that so I want to come back
in a bit to talking about like how could
the body not be in our control what does
he mean by that but first I want to talk
about something else that's really
important and that is the use of
external things
so you could say internals are in our
control externals not in our control
right
Epictetus says that yeah those those
outside things those in difference like
for example my iPhone here piece of
property an incredibly powerful computer
device that I used to run you know many
aspects of my life and my business not
really in my control I mean
shows me that every time that they want
to do an update and I can't use my phone
for a little while or it starts slowing
down because they've changed the
software or and we can go on and on and
on and on right and the battery can
drain very very quickly
there's all sorts of things that that
just demonstrate you over and over again
that this piece of property that's so
important to us is not in our control my
use of it my dealing with it in Greek
crisis I'm actually gonna write this
down for people because I think they may
find that it's interesting
it's this is the sort of romanized new
way of doing and I'm not going to try to
use Greek characters but traceless means
dealing with or or use how it is that we
comport ourselves with something that is
in our control that is not something
indifferent according to the Stoics that
has an impact so swinging back now to
the body right I don't
ultimately control my body there are all
these processes going on my body is a
sort of locus of vulnerability to the
world for me I can walk out of my my
apartment and get hit by the bus now you
know that doesn't mean I shouldn't look
both ways before crossing the street but
I could look both ways and be a little
bit distracted and a Prius could take me
out right because you can't hear them
coming with hair when they're on their
hybrid thing or all sorts of other
things we can imagine comic book cartoon
and stuff you know a safe falls down and
hits me on the head diseases you know
endemics we are we are now at the stage
where we thought we had total control
over disease and we're giving everybody
antibiotics and lo and behold the
bacteria have evolved resistance to them
and now we have these you know terrible
infections that are very difficult to
deal with and anybody could get them
right and I can work out I can do all
the things that I ought to do with my
body
Epictetus is really clear he uses all
these working out metaphors you probably
should work out your body he also thinks
you should do basic hygiene
keep your body clean there's an entire
chapter on that and I think it's in book
three or book for the
discourses right but you can do all that
and your body can still be not what it
is that you want the older that you get
the more you see about that you know for
instance I mean if I really wanted to be
if I was pretty vain I might you know
dye my beard and my mustache which you
notice are basically two different
colors right a mustaches all this brown
and and then why did it my beard has all
this just plain white in it you look at
some pictures of me five years ago it
was all you know brown and black well
you know I can dye it I don't have any
control over how the hair grows in you
know same thing with you know I need to
wear these glasses I do have control
over whether I put them on or not but I
don't change you know the way my eyes
are I suppose I could go and do LASIK
right but we can we can go on and on and
on with examples like this the basic
idea is that you know there there are so
many things that we we control the the
use of it but we don't control the
outcome the trichotomy that irvine was
proposing in saying that we internalize
our goals and you know we we play tennis
we play to the best of our ability but
we don't control whether we win the
match that's exactly what epictetus was
saying only he didn't see a need to
posit a trichotomy he's not that fit
into a dichotomy of control the other
thing that I do want to bring up in
terms of the dichotomy of control that I
know a lot of people express concerns
about you know epictetus on the other
side right what is in our control so our
thoughts are our choices our desires and
our versions you know whether we give
assent to things or not all of these
sorts of things
Epictetus says are in our control and
that might lead you to the idea that he
thinks that they are directly in our
control and that we never encounter kind
of opposition within which is totally
not the case
this is why epictetus emphasizes the
role of the Stoics in general did the
role of habit when we've already created
habits of approaching things in a
certain way it's almost like they work
on autopilot and and we
to do a lot to catch ourselves even just
to notice that we've got a hang of it
first of all and then to slowly wean
ourselves away from that and eventually
to substitute a different habit that
does not happen overnight and so you
know epictetus talks about for example
in your if you if you manage to if
you're an angry person and you're manage
to go a couple days without getting
angry that's good if you go 30 days he
says that's amazing sacrifice to God and
you've probably managed to establish a
new habit I've never gone more than a
week well whose thing my temper right
and I'm working on this this artist
stuff and I think all of us can relate
to this in one way or another there are
going to be some things that are that
that are internal but seem to us to be
much less in our control
Epictetus isn't saying that that you
automatically can snap your fingers and
then suddenly you know if you've fallen
in love with somebody but you realize
that they're bad for you you're not
going to just like switch a switch in
your brain and suddenly everything is
great and you don't have any desire for
that person right or if you have a
phobia a kind of aversion toward
something you're not going to just
suddenly wake up one day and not be
worried about Sanel closed spaces or
spiders there's public speaking those
sorts of things it takes work and and
that's something that he recognizes so
it's important to keep that in
perspective let me look at now at the
control panel and see what we got now
there's quite a few questions already so
I'm gonna give priority to questions
that are actually about the Stoics and
things like that actually I'll address
something at the start I should do a
stream with the partially examined life
I actually did a stream with the
partially examined life a long time ago
on Nietzsche they brought me in because
you know they needed somebody who's got
a background in Nietzsche and they never
called me back again so if you want me
on the partial examine life I would
hector them until they they want to
bring me back on i have written on on
their blog
so you know clearly they're interested
in that and they're actually just down
the road the guy who runs it is based in
Madison so if you want to see me on it
more I think you know send them an email
here here's a another one from Robert
Woolston do the ancient stoic sore
Epicureans make a distinction between
the proper balance of focusing on virtue
and ethics and acquiring material
possessions or social concerns like
reputation yeah though the proper
balance for the Stoics is that virtue
gets the highest priority but you know
you certainly can devote yourself to to
you know making a living and to
maintaining your reputation this is
where the Stoics differed from like the
cynics for example and you know you
place it into a proper perspective I'd
say if you want to see that at work take
a look at what Epicurus epictetus is
saying in the discourses take a look at
Cicero's works where he presents that
and also another author who's not all
that widely read but talks quite a bit
about this is arias didymus in his
epitome of stoic ethics Epicureans yes
they also did that as well
they focused mostly on how this would
impact our pleasures and pains because
that's that's central for them
unfortunately we don't have very much
epicurean literature from the ancient
period we even don't really have that
much of what the Stoics wrote so that
that's too bad
I want to give a shout-out to my my son
who is watching right now he just texted
me to tell me so that's really cool he
is a budding youtuber and may have an
interest in someday becoming a
philosopher I don't know if an academic
sense but he and I talk about these
things as I do with other members of my
family but I just thought that's really
cool that he's he is watching so alright
um let's see why okay I'm gonna skip
over the art thing and maybe come back
to that let's see if we can get to some
stoic stuff oh here's a good one
the dichotomy seems to relate to
conceptions of freewill the Stoics are
often portrayed as having a
compatibilist viewpoint do you think
this is accurate or they're important
nuances there so there's a lot to be
said about that first of all the notion
of free will is an ambiguous notion so
when somebody starts saying oh there is
no such thing as free will or
neuroscience this or determinism that I
always want to say well what do you
actually mean by free will because not
everybody has the same conception and so
a lot of the times people are disproving
free will over here but it's not what
other people mean by it that said the
Stoics themselves did not develop a
robust conception of free will as such
Epictetus talks about the Pro I raices
which is the Faculty of choice which is
almost the will if we look at what you
don't say Augustine means by the will
but it's not exactly the same thing so
you know you got to be you got to be a
little bit careful with that
I see somebody saying oh can we abandon
this free will issue silly issue no it's
not a silly issue as a matter of fact I
think it's so important I've written
articles on it and so it may seem silly
to you but it's not silly and there's
good reasons why people have talked
about that so this issue of
compatibilism let's say we get away from
the word freewill and we talk in terms
about freedom of choice and and we think
about whether we have any freedom to
make things go one way or the other or
whether we're just driven by some
outside forces or internal programming
or something like that
then we get away from some of the
emotional worries that I think people
have about about that that term and
maybe get away from some of the the
baggage that that holds people back and
the stomachs then yes are compatible
estate that everything is ultimately
part of one large interlocking cause
process and yet at the same time there
are free clauses I mean Aristotle also
has the same sort of thing self move
movers part of this gigantic you know
interesting system and if you want to
see a really great work talking about
this
although unfortunates fragmentary
because we've washed parts of the text
read Cicero's on fate he summarizes what
some of the ancients had to think about
this issue and he talks about the
epicurean position a couple other
positions the epicurean said this you
know famous swerve and when you see
people appealing to like quantum
mechanics today they're in essence doing
the same sort of argument that that
Epicurious and the Epicureans were
that's this real found very unconvincing
it's an issue that's gonna run all the
way down to the present you know many of
the other people that i do a lot of work
out like the John Paul Sartre for
example discuss it
Sartre also points out that most of the
ways in which philosophers have been
discussing it is rather artificial so
that's probably enough about about that
at that at that point and just to
respond why do you think we should care
about freewill just curious if you don't
care about it don't care about it the
rest of us do you know nobody's gonna
push it out on you I think that's don't
worry about it so let's go back to some
of the other things I was a good
question what is the best stoic to begin
with I get asked this quite often I am I
will admit that I am a big fan of
epictetus I really do like you know
Marcus Aurelius I really do like Seneca
who sonjia's Rufus is interesting
although we don't have that much of him
Arius didymus was pretty cool too but my
you know I don't know I guess I guess
you could say my heart belongs to
epictetus there's something about him
and his approach that that I really
enjoy it could be a function of you know
the guy who wrote his stuff down arias
the this historian who model himself by
the way after after Xenophon student of
Socrates also a military commander
historian and chronicler of his great
teacher so there's kind of an
interesting historical precedent and I
think that a lot of people get
introduced to stoicism through one of
three main sources when when they're
talking about you know classic sources I
know a lot of people get introduced to
stoicism through reading you know more
more contemporary works whether they be
you know really solid it ones or some
sense very academic works or whether
they're much more popularly oriented I
think it's really important to go back
to the primary sources if if you're only
getting stoicism from reading secondary
contemporary literature or watching
videos or listening to podcasts you're
not really getting it from the source
and I think you're depriving yourself
with something important so Senecas
letters is a big one Epictetus is
ingredien and then of course Marcus
Aurelius is Marcus Aurelius is
meditations so you know you can
certainly read the meditations they're
there they're great you can certainly
read Senecas letters that's that's kind
of long but the uncrating is nice and
short it's also not all that it's not as
representative of Epictetus when you
read the discourses so it in a way it
offers a kind of interesting launching
point because people can read it be like
what the hell what's he talking about
here right and then exact well you know
here's the fuller doctrine in the
discourses and sometimes that kind of
intellectual contact is very good let's
say let's see here I like how ik Titus
describes how we control our own desires
but if our desires were in another body
we'd have no interest in them from an
ordered whole that's an interesting idea
I mean who does that ever happen to it's
kind of a we're in the realm of thought
experiments several degrees removed from
reality at that point
I don't know I'd have to think about
that I don't really have something you
know interesting or intelligent to say
about that kind of thought experiment at
that point playlist writes do you have
any recommendations on how to retain
information of one's highest potential
is it something that largely comes
naturally or would you recommend faman
lectures shout out to your son
I wouldn't recommend Fineman lectures
because I don't watch them so I can't
recommend them I don't know if they're
good or bad how to retain information
someone's highest potential I really
have much to say about that because I
was always kind of in a weird boat
because I remembered a awful lot of
stuff I do often not remember things
that I should remember that are a bit
more like mundane and and I don't have
such great control over what I do
remember and don't remember unless I
actively work to put things to memory I
mean when it comes to like the history
of philosophy there's nothing like
actually waiting your way through the
text time and time again well tell you
kind of an interesting story one of the
reasons why besides just doing wide
reading and and having a real interest
in what I was reading one of the reasons
why I know the history of philosophy so
well is because of something that we had
to do in graduate school which
unfortunately my graduate school like
many others has since abandoned as a
practice for graduate students it was
what was called preliminary examinations
and that was at the PhD level you also
had to take a comprehensive examination
at the Masters level and these were
tests you get three and a half hours you
had to answer questions essay questions
out of a pool right so the comps you had
three questions in ancient three
questions and medieval three questions
in modern three questions in 19th
century philosophy and if you couldn't
answer any of the three you were screwed
you failed right and so you would pick
one of them and then you would have to
answer it and I actually got a low pass
on my comps in part because I wrote you
know
in a very Ciceronian style you know one
of the complaints was your first
paragraph was 16 your first sentence was
16 lines long on a blue book paper and I
was like who cares did I get it right or
not you know but it was that sort of
stuff and so for the prelims you had a
much wider reading list we had to do one
prelim on metaphysics and philosophy
religion one on epistemology and
philosophy of science one on value
fields which was aesthetics you know
politics ethics and then one on your
special thinker nay chose Hegel for my
special thinker and you know when I said
well what do I need to study for the the
Hegel exam my the professor in charge
said just memorize the phenomenology you
know the basic structure of it so I did
I actually did that he said by the way
there will be some stuff on the science
of logic as well so I went through that
and paid close attention of that as well
but for the other things you know like
think about the metaphysics right you
got this reading list and it was
incredibly wrong long and and your
questions that you might get asked could
be anything from that reading list so it
could be anything from you know Plato's
dialogues to stoic stuff to de Kurt's
meditations and what's going on in there
to contempt you know 20th century stuff
it was from you know history of
philosophy some analytic writers some
continental writers some classical
American writers and so there were two
ways to go about this you could try to
game it and and hope that you might get
questions that actually answered to the
things that you'd studied or you could
do it I did and what some of my other
colleagues that I've talked about this
did and read it all and learn it all and
somehow keep all of that in your head
for a while no I can't say that I
actually have retained all of that right
but I retained a good bit of it and when
I got thrown into my first teaching
situation where I had to teach a whole
bunch of different classes I you know I
knew a lot of these thinkers at a
sufficient level to be able to
communicate them to somebody
I'll mention in just in case he's
watching somebody who is very strong
proponent of continuing to keep these
Tom Alexander one of the professors at
Southern Illinois University you know he
he made a good argument for why they
should be kept and unfortunately they
weren't and I think that it's there's a
kind of an academic hazing but it really
was good for us though that went through
it and did it the right way that's a
little bit of a long discussion of that
all right here's a great question that I
think I may have skipped over what about
people who are mentally ill do they
really have control over their attitude
and thoughts so when you put it like
that the answer is yes and no they they
do have control over some of their
thoughts right they may not have control
over all of their thoughts so think
about somebody with a terrible phobia
now the question is do they have control
over their thoughts at you know the time
that they're experiencing things or does
that mean that they never have control
over those thoughts that they can't work
at it in some way and there are some
varieties of what we classify as mental
illness and and actually you know going
back to ancient philosophy they talked
about mental disease as well but they
thought philosophy could be useful in
working at it and this is what we in
fact find you know there are therapeutic
approaches that that draw heavily on
stoicism you know the whole cognitive
approach originally good bit of that is
coming out of stoicism if you're
interested in positive psychology well I
think Seligman gets Aristotle wrong but
you know Reid's the Maris toddle if
you're interested in the emotional
intelligence approach which is much less
about mental illness and much more about
other things you know that begins with a
quote by Aristotle so ancient philosophy
does have some hooks for that but you
know there there will be some things you
know that that are not as amenable to
applying you know stoic philosophy as a
therapy but that doesn't mean that you
can't do any
I think we have really got to avoid this
on/off black/white thinking about about
that we want to make distinctions this
is something very important in
philosophy and in life in general being
able to do something isn't the same
thing as being able to do nothing but
it's not the same thing as having
absolute total control right and so we
you know we want to think our way
through this there's a lot of things
that we classify as mental illnesses or
as disorders that are you know to some
degree tractable from from using
philosophical resources and tools it can
get to the point where you know if your
brain chemistry is is really screwed up
you can you know tell yourself as much
as you like but that's not going to
actually help you in that case sometimes
medication is the answer and it and for
many people you know altering the brain
chemistry and working on oneself these
can go hand-in-hand so that's it's
pretty important let's see here I got a
scroll up a bit because it's not
suddenly jumped oh great question for
Natasha how can we make the dichotomy of
control a regular stoic practice so that
is that's really at the core of how to
put this stuff into play one way is to
remind oneself of it in situations where
it applies right so something goes wrong
and you ask yourself wait a second is
this something that's in my control is
it something that's not in my control if
it's not in my control then I'm not
really being harmed by it and maybe I
shouldn't be so emotionally invested in
it I I know I feel bad right now but but
maybe I should you know you know adopt a
different perspective and maybe I can
only make partial success with that
right we can also go into situations
ahead of time
thinking about well what what parts of
this are in my control what parts of
this are not in my control and you see
Epictetus advocating doing exactly that
in the enchiridion for instance when you
go to the baths right like when we go to
the public pool or go to the gym or go
to the movie theater say to yourself you
know what what is what am I going here
to do to keep my Faculty of choice in
accordance with nature maybe don't
express it to yourself like that because
that's a little abstract path I want to
own it keep my cool right and then think
to yourself well I am going to the movie
theater hopefully getting to see the
movie without people acting like
jackasses around me but if they do and I
say something and they they still act
like jackasses I don't really have
control over that so I don't have to let
that interfere with that he talks about
people splashing you at the baths and
stealing your stuff I think that happens
at the public pool right and then people
playing their music too loud and we
could go on and on and on and on with
examples like this you're you know
you're on your commute to work and you
think about the co-workers or their boss
your customers that you're gonna have to
deal with some of them are a treat some
of them aren't you can think about
what's in your control and what's what's
not in your control so the Stoics I
actually suggest you having ready to
hand sort of sayings dog Motta
about about these sorts of things all
right let me take a few more here on
free will from Marcos is free will more
connected with atheists a lot of people
say God willing so is there a contrast
to be made no free listened more
connected with atheist there's I mean
well most of the great world religious
traditions say that that human beings do
have free will and you know there's
often some sort of story that has to be
told about how this can be compatible
with divine foreknowledge or stuff like
that they're not simple stories but
they're they're interesting stories so I
don't I don't see it as necessarily
connected with with atheism saying God
willing or fate willing or anything like
that is just sort of you know the Starks
call that the this reserve clause right
um things could go my way they could
satisfy my desires or maybe not right so
here's a one from playlist isn't free
well largely limiting doing due to the
disposition we find ourself in or do you
take this into account at illustrating
your ideas and Street will a choice
built up library things we know not
really quite sure how to respond to that
but I think so I'm going to interpret
that it isn't free will it's a largely
limited due to the disposition we find
ourselves in yeah nobody says that free
will means that you can do anything
whatsoever at any time choose anything
possible there's always some
conditioning going on right and I think
this is where a lot of people get get
mixed up they're like yeah if you
believe in free will you think that like
you can do anything
no you can choose sometimes just between
very very narrow options right or you
know you can adopt a tiny little bit of
freedom but it's still some some freedom
and and that's all we need to have in
order it is to say that there is some
freedom of choice let's scroll down yeah
X rights discourse has shed so much more
light into the enchiridion methodology
well the enchiridion is a best hits list
pulled out of the discourses not just
the four books that we possess but the
four lost books that we unfortunately
don't have and again stoic literature
there's so much stuff that you know it
would be so cool if we had it and you
never know they might discover some
scroll somewhere and unroll it and
here's you know
Zeno's on choice or xenos republic or
one of cruciferous as many writings or
works by Pinay theists or even some of
the ones that we hardly ever talk about
like you know Diogenes of Babylon or
Auntie Potter you know these other
interesting guys but that's not probably
going to happen so you know if you
really want to know epictetus you want
to go to the discourses and they're
really I think they're well worth
spending the time with
[Music]
all right ordered whole has a question
about stoic physics and it's connection
with ethics what do you think about the
stoic assumption of the universal
natural logos and a dichotomy of
controls this is a good question because
this is something where I think a lot of
modern Stoics and modern look is a broad
term right and we're kind of in the
middle of an interesting set of debates
and discussions about precisely what it
would it entails and encompasses by the
way a plug we just talked about that
with an online symposium in stoicism
today earlier with seven people weighing
in and then John sellers and I had our
pieces in the last week on Wednesday so
I think that you can make the stoic
ethics work without assuming the stoic
physics I don't think that you have to
buy into sort of pantheism or even the
notion of Providence I think the other
stuff works without that and I think
many modern Stoics don't don't buy into
that traditional stoic say look it's
it's it's it's the whole thing or
nothing right don't call yourself a
stoic unless you actually do believe
that there's like a logos permeating
everything I I don't I I'm more
attracted to the modern stoic
perspective insofar as I am any sort of
stoic because I'm actually more of an
eclectic than a stoic but yeah so oh
here's a good one for Marco's in your
courses to use primary sources
exclusively or our secondary texts
useful secondary texts are useful never
get to them because not enough time
right if I'm teaching an ethics class
I've had to already cut out you know a
good 30 tacks that I would like to teach
in their primary texts that we're not
going to get to so we're gonna stick
just in the class time that we have with
with primary text so if people want to
read secondary text that's fine I even
give them the equivalent of that with
lesson pages and videos
that because everything I do is
essentially secondary literature right
but I think it's it's important to
engage primary texts that especially in
if we're thinking about like traditional
college education this may be the one
time that a student has the opportunity
to study a classic or contemporary
author with somebody who actually
hopefully knows you know what what the
hell that person is saying and can
explain it to them and leave them
further into it
unfortunately not all philosophy
instructors are actually up to that we
probably should some screening and
review process but that'll never happen
for the people who are who are teaching
so you know secondary literature is nice
myself I don't have the time to get to
it unless I'm unless I'm researching
something you know like if I'm gonna
write a paper on epictetus there's
certain people who you can bet I'm going
to be bringing it up you know long you
know probably sellers right certainly
Christopher Gill I'm very fortunate in
that by being a member of the modern
stoicism organization I get to chat with
these guys who are these you know really
top-notch people I'm talking about
stoicism an emotion Garver definitely
you know you go down the down the list
right and and it's a same thing for
Aristotle bigger group of people working
on Aristotle who else do I typically
write on Anselm Hobbes you know those
are those are people where I dunno the
secondary lit and I stay on top of it
that's because I'm doing academic
writing as well as more public and
popular stuff that's not to say that you
know secondary literature is bad I mean
if you're reading a history of
philosophy and it helps you kind of
figure out where these these people fit
in relation to each other that's good
but I think it's always important to go
back to the primary texts blacked a
really interesting question here can you
recommend any philosophers who are not
Stoics but they share a lot of common
themes that's a great question so I'm
gonna say two things one is that if
you're thinking in terms of virtue
ethics there's a really great piece
by long that's responding to Alistair
McIntyre's workwear McIntyre is saying
that you know in the contemporary
setting you know with virtue ethics we
really have one main you know sort of
you call it tradition to rely upon and
that's the Aristotelian tradition
mediated them through the Thomas
tradition later on and and that you know
this would be the most robust form of
virtue ethics and there's a great
argument to be made that no stoicism is
really doing a lot of the same stuff
that McIntyre was was proposing and
laying out and so that you know the
stoic and an Aristotelian traditions
could kind of support each other that's
the way I look at it that's why cicero
looked at it too by the way big fan of
Cicero there's there's other there's
plenty of other thinkers and and
movements that are that are taking on
some of the same issues as the Stoics
you know if you think about like
Christian thought or even some some you
know Jewish thought you know like a
think about some of the the non
canonical texts like fourth Maccabees
pretty stoic you know feel of Alexandria
you know well really anybody coming from
Alexandria knows their stoicism as well
as their their their Platonism so you
know whether it's filo on the Jewish
side or Clement on the Christian side
they're gonna talk about that sort of
stuff locked on seus another great great
example of somebody who takes some stuff
and says well the stoic seem to be right
about this wrong about that and so these
common themes come up a lot of people
want to bring together in some way or
another stoicism and what they're
calling existentialism usually meaning
Sartre existentialism because there's a
lot of varieties of existentialism and
there are a lot of common themes right
taking responsibility for how you
respond in situations thinking about
what you have freedom in relation to and
what you don't have freedom in
relationship these are very important
ideas and so I think there's there's a
lot of interesting connections there
um let's see
ah there was a good one
jawed Wigga are there any contemporary
full-blown stomachs that right Massimo
Pigliucci just just published a book
ought to be a stoic right he's probably
one of the most famous converts Lawrence
Becker is a new stoicism which a lot of
the people who are in in the sort of
contemporary modern stoic movement at a
high level you know where they they they
really spend a lot of time with the
contemporary texts no Becker's work
which is quite good Bill Irvine you know
Donald Robertson a lot of these are
people that you see in a modern stoicism
organization right so you know we can go
on and on and on there's a lot of people
writing on stoicism by the way I should
mention one of the things that I had
been meaning to do for a couple months
and I'm finally gonna get it knocked out
this month and I'm going to do some of
it this weekend is some book reviews
myself on not just stoic but other other
literature dealing with like philosophy
and how to live it out in contemporary
life so you might want to watch for some
of those videos I'm also working on a
book although like I said I'm more of an
eclectic than a stoic and the one that
I'm currently working on which is a
detour from one of the other ones I'm
supposed to be working on has to do with
this notion of in accordance with nature
and what is what what does that mean
when the Stoics are talking about that
right because it's an ambiguous term and
how does it apply to to our lives I'm
also working on a book on stoicism and
anger as well let's see here
Robert writes some people associate
stoicism as being without emotion or
emotionless for the Stoics how do you
properly deal with or control our
emotions
yeah the Stoics they are not emotionless
as a matter of fact they recognize
certain emotions as being good and as
even to some degree being you might say
obligatory for us right we ought to feel
certain ways at certain times so you
know what would be examples of that
familial affection Stoics think that
it's natural for you to care about your
kids or your parents or your siblings
and you see this discussed in in
Epictetus you'll also see this discussed
in other places and then if you ever get
your hands on here achlys you know his
ethics that's you know he talks about it
in terms of a key osis you might might
come across that term so that's that's
an emotional state that that's
considered good marcus talks in terms of
affection love you know towards other
people sort of seneca to some degree the
Stoics in general recognized that there
were good emotions but they would be
emotions that are sort of within the
scope of rationality they help us to to
fully realize what it is to be a human
being many of the other emotions that we
feel like you know various forms of fear
anger they were always like against
anger jealousy envy you know hatred
these sorts of things they they thought
that those were bad for us they're
they're bad in how they affect us
they're bad and how they they make us
act now how do we properly deal with
their control our emotions part of it is
recognizing what's going on so we almost
like a mechanics of how emotions work
and the Stoics did provide that and then
we got to work on a bit by bit you know
if I'm if I'm an angry person I probably
need not just to you know restrain
myself from saying stupid things and
doing dumb things but also looking to
well what am i angry about do I have
good grounds to be angry and doing some
of that that work and I think a lot of
times that is you know you can do that
on your own it's often good to do that
with a coach or a counselor or somebody
like that and I mean the good news is is
you're dealing with things that are kind
of universal human conditions so if
you're struggling with anger it's not
like your anger is
medically different than everybody
else's so presumably we have some
guidelines for how to deal with it lose
an interesting one I think a follow-up
how should one deal with the sense of
being indifferent to one's intense
emotions to avoid suffering like love
somehow depreciates or degrades its
objects that like it wasn't so important
at all well a patinas talks about this
so in that famous passage where he says
when you kiss your wife or your child
remind yourself that they are human and
they're going to die and people are like
that's really cold and I don't want to
be a stoic if that's what being a stoic
is like and in that passage a lot of
people also respond they're like well
you don't really love your your kid or
your spouse if you if you have that
attitude in that very passage it says
with things that you find useful or
entertaining or towards which you feel
affection Phyllis toward yeah right so
you do feel affection but you can you
can you know with with it's not
withdrawing the affection it's realizing
that you're also dealing with mortal
decomposable beings that are the way
that they are so when they die
you're not as troubled I think a lot of
people think that if you're not super
upset then you've never really cared at
all and the storks would say is that
really true is there a necessary
connection between those and the answer
is no you know there isn't and maybe
it's a delusion to think that that you
know we have to like you know wail and
throw ourselves on the coffin or
something like that or we didn't really
care same thing with with with with love
right you know our if we if we realize
that we're you know madly in love with
somebody I mean it's not like the Stoics
are gonna say oh well if you're madly in
love you have to stop that nonsense
right now but you know if you realize
that the person is abusive or just maybe
not the right person for you you might
want to resist that that feeling you
might want to tell yourself that you
know maybe you're you're feeling is off
base
so I think that's probably enough let's
see here oh I just skip down a bunch
looks like there's a lot of questions
okay Natasha has a rather technical
question which is good are things within
our control preferred dis prefer ders is
only externals things outside of our
control so it's it's indifference that
are preferred and dis preferred in
general I guess you could say that like
a given thought it could be preferred in
that it leads you to acting virtuously
or just preferred in that it leads you
to acting unvirtuous li but or viciously
but it's going to be part of a complex
usually we talk about the things that
are external and our prefer to just
prefer like wealth health victory you
know there's like a whole list of these
endogenous layer tastes in cicero and in
areas didymus is epitome of stoic ethics
[Music]
so i think it's primarily gonna be
applying to externals it depends on how
we want to look at things like
individual thoughts individual desires I
guess if we look at them individually we
could maybe say some of them are in
difference but I think if we look at
them in their larger structure which is
where they they live right in her minds
no they're not going to be that way
here's an interesting one bite by JP is
stoicism inherently conservative depends
on what you mean by conservative it's
interesting to see stoicism used kind of
embedded all around by people from all
ends of the political spectrum there are
some people who are like stoicism means
a commitment to social justice and by
social justice they don't mean what
earlier generations meant by social
justice like what you see in John Stuart
Mill or you know Catholic encyclicals on
social justice but you know there
a contemporary hard left stuff right and
you can in fact corral stoicism in and
make it do that but I think you lose
something of it in the process likewise
there's people on the hard right who
want to try to use elements of stoicism
to do similar things right and they
ignore the fact that you know the Stoics
were Cosmopolitan's that they didn't
think that just conservativism for its
own sake was great there's all this
nonsense about you know fuchsias
manliness you can get a little bit of
that out of Cicero but if then if you
read more Cicero you'd be like oh I was
wrong about that right and so people use
it you know and then other people try to
use stoicism basically just to make a
buck right you know they'll come out
with something they'll take some
business leadership theory and take a
few words and then add in some stoic
quotes and they're like hey you know buy
my package right so people can do that I
think that if we look at authentic stoic
sources and people who are more in the
mainstream there they're not they're
gonna be involved with politics but
they're not going to be happy with any
party that we currently have here in the
United States I don't know about in
other places and they're probably going
to be fairly unpopular if they do get
involved in a particular party or
movement because they're the ones who
are often saying hey guys I realize that
we're fighting the good fight but we
probably shouldn't be doing this then
everyone's like shut up you know you
were fighting the good fight that's all
that matters right so I don't see that
as inherently conservative I think that
the stoicism if you take it seriously I
often when people ask me you know water
my political views I tell them I don't
have a single party that's congenial to
me and I'm too traditional to be
conservative and I'm not traditional in
the sense that the traditional lists are
I think they're just conservatives of a
different stripe and I think stoicism
works that way too and I think
Aristotelian ism works that way too and
Platonism and a lot a lot of these
things
here's a question from an ordered whole
is the goal to see philosophy as a guide
to happiness something we've abandoned
in academic philosophy yeah I would say
a lot but for those of us that that read
whether we're in academics I had one
foot still in academia and one foot
outside of it it doesn't have to be that
way and I think there are some there you
know a lot of institutions where they do
recognize that think about like it here
just down south in Chicago Center for
practical wisdom probably about
happiness right there's all sorts of
great great Institute's like that let me
put in a plug two for one that I'm going
to be doing some collaborations with
these upcoming months the New Acropolis
in Chicago where I will be giving a
stoic week talk on Tuesday I believe
it's the 17th so if you're in the
Chicagoland area you might want to check
that out and I'll also be giving a talk
there for International philosophy day
they they asked me if I'd come down and
and give a talk and so I'm really happy
to be collaborating with with them we
also the stoic week event by the way for
those of you in the Greater Milwaukee
area or if you're in the Chicago area
and want to drive up or if you're
Madison want to drive over or the Fox
Cities and want to drive down here at
the Shorewood Public Library on Thursday
I believe it's the 19th we're going to
talk about stoicism in the workplace so
some fun stuff ordered whole as to the
skeptics have a similar dichotomy of
control not that I know of but you know
that's a tradition that I don't spend
that much time with so I don't really
know let's see if we got some more oh
there's a good little terminological
question from Claire I've been listening
to audiobooks and stoicism by Ancients
what does according to their desserts
mean I don't know if that's the correct
spelling so that's a good question this
is a word that we don't use in the same
way anymore
it means according to what people
deserve what they merit right and and
and you might think it has to do
something with like the the meal or the
course that comes after dinner right
desserts I guess you could say well if
you're not a good person you don't
deserve dessert remember but when we
talk about somebody getting their just
desserts we mean that if they're a good
person they get good things if they're a
bad person they get bad things right
Andy writes you'd be surprised how often
we discuss philosophy while cooking some
tasty food in our house yes we we both
share a love for the culinary arts annie
is a amazing cook I'm a good cook and we
do a lot of things and I actually do
some things with philosophy and food I
did a talk a while back you can find the
video on the four tastes in are the 80s
sorry yeah four flavors are what we're
combative the eight flavors in Aristotle
and how it goes forward into you know
all the way up to the 19th century let's
see here an order hold the stoicism
systemic it sure is and anybody who
tries to you know tell you that it's not
and you can just sort of like pick and
choose whatever you like I don't think
that's real stoicism but that's that's
me right the ashtrays what is some good
entry to Seneca you know the letters I
would say he also has some some treaty
sees that are good the on anger is
particularly useful I think so I check
that out
funny funny question so we actually have
a couple that I'm gonna try to answer as
we come to the end
[Music]
one is about me am i a centrist do you
think this is a sort of niche many
philosophers will eventually occupy yeah
but the trouble is is that centrism
means a lot of different things so
there's some people who are centrist
just because they're like totally
disconnected and couldn't care less
who's in charge there's some more
centrist cuz they're like you know in
that oh I'd be totally fair to every
side kind of kind of thing and I think
that can actually be vicious sometimes
then there's some who are centrist
because they just don't belong anywhere
else and that's where I am and our
philosopher is gonna be there I don't
know you know I I wouldn't look for a
hell of a lot to come from academic
philosophers there they're kind of in
you know there somebody brought up the
word decadence before I think you can
say that about a lot of academic
philosophy unfortunately it's sad to say
about my profession but there's a lot of
shortsightedness a lot of reacting out
of fear or indifference to others so
Christopher asked can I talk about how
Epictetus influenced Aaron back in the
cognitive behavioral psychology well it
influenced Albert Ellis first and then
Ellis influenced Beck and I know if you
look through the the cognitive behavior
psychology stuff that's still conscious
of where it came from originally or read
Donald Robertson's you know philosophy
of CBT that's that's great he's somebody
who's you know very familiar with all of
that stuff cuz he practices it and E is
a great stoic writer you're gonna see
that they drew you know a lot of a lot
of ideas from destruction particularly
from epictetus so here's a funny one
from coffee coffee smug what's the
relation between Conte and the Stoics
was Conte a big big stoic fanboy I
wouldn't call him a fanboy I think
there's some similarities between Conte
and stoicism but I think there's also
some really big dissimilarity so the
Stoics are you die monistic they they
think that you know behaving in a way to
fulfill our duties cultivating the
virtues all of that sort of stuff
behaving in a rash
well fashion is going to make us happy
and Khan says happiness is not what
ethics is about at all
as a matter of fact I've got a core
concept video specifically on that that
you might want to take a look at and
can't count I think it's a different
understanding of happiness though so
there might be a bit of equivocation
going on there a lot of other people
like for example Alistair McIntyre have
thought of the Stoics is basically being
sort of like proto conscience I think
that's a wrong approach here's a couple
other things do it you do I think modern
shows from Ruby do I think modern
stomachs that like momentum Morris are
wrong and using old Roman coins etc
shouldn't we use objects to remember
death relevant to us today I guess if
that sort of thing helps you if like
pulling out a coin or a token or
something helps you to carry out the you
know reminding yourself that you're
mortal and everybody else is mortal
that's that's good I I don't need that
myself but I don't begrudge anybody else
using whatever props they want I think
that you know whenever we're doing is a
little bit of a soapbox thing whenever
we're doing anything that has to do with
like public philosophy we should
probably make whatever we're doing as
affordable as possible for as many
people to be able to enjoy it so if
somebody's making a ton of money on
selling memento mori coins I that's
probably not stoic right almost they're
selling them in such bulk that everybody
thinks they're they're a great thing is
my book for sale I'm in the Chicagoland
area and a signed copy of reason
fulfilled my Revolution revelation in
addition to my library yeah it is that
you can get it on the Amazon anything if
you want to like get it directly from
CUA press you could although I think
they may charge you more and you if you
run into me and you've got it
I'll definitely sign it so if you show
up at the stoical week event I'll be
happy to do that
it's not about stoicism I should mention
though it's about the Christian
philosophy debates and there
there is I'm gonna go over a little bit
of time and then we'll wrap it up an
ordered holes the internet the
cosmopolitan idea the Stoics had in mind
I do not think so all you got to do is
read through not my comment sections but
a lot of other youtube comment sections
and you'll be wading through a swamp of
negativity if that's what a cosmopolitan
is of this they're like lowest common
denominator that just keeps getting
lower and lower and lower coming from
all over the world that's not what the
Stoics same thing I think with a lot of
what goes on on Twitter or Facebook or
things like that I mean there's great
potential right I mean think about what
we're doing right here this is amazing
and and thirty years ago this is only
science fiction the fact that right now
I've got 70 people probably all over the
world watching this writing you know
questions that I'm answering and it's
streaming and it'll be recorded that's
amazing stuff but if I would do it let
me put it through this way if this was a
video about my cats or I was doing
makeup tutorials or I was talking about
in an angry way about politics or sports
or you know what beer I like or
something like that it wouldn't be 60
you know 70 viewers it would be a
thousand viewers or a million viewers so
I don't know you know the Internet is
really living up to its potential so
let's see what else we got
Ruby asks can I talk about the Tetra
Pharma coasts you know maybe I'll do a
session specifically on epicureanism
down the line for some more pop
philosophy pop ups but I'm not gonna I'm
not going to do that right now because
this is you know for stoicism and a
video about cats could be philosophical
yeah I'd have to think about how that
would happen yeah even if you did make
it philosophical less people would
probably tune in
so I don't I don't I don't know what
that the answer to that is so let me say
thank you to everybody who showed up
asked questions left comments as usual I
very much enjoyed this and I hope that
you found it good as well
and well we do these every month my
patreon supporters find out about when
they're scheduled at the very beginning
of the month everybody else you know
social media I announce it the day of I
do one of these on Facebook live and one
of these on YouTube live each month let
me put in a plug as well so if you're if
you don't already have tickets to
snowicon' and stoic context Toronto it's
too late for that now I think those of
you who are going to be at stoic on you
know come by say hello I'm very friendly
as you can tell you'll have to remind me
sometimes you are because it's still
account is such a blur but we will be
having those those stoic week events if
you're interested in stoicism you
definitely want to sign up if you
haven't done it already for the stoic
week free online course you can find
that at the modern stoicism website and
I think that's pretty much yet you know
stoicism go this month not that we
shouldn't practice this stuff in other
months but this is like the month
October where it gets a lot of worldwide
attention it's a really cool class I do
it every year
even though it's it's kind of beginner
level stuff because it's kind of like
nice - it's a tune tune back up Andy and
I both do it together it provides us
with some great conversation so if
you've got you know a friend to do it
with or you know a partner that's even
better you get to discuss you know what
you're talking about
if there's a local event near you we're
publicizing the events on the moderate
and stoicism website so you might want
to check and see whether there's
anything around you or if there's a you
know a group of people that you can
participate in the stoic week course
with and that's all the plugs that I've
got for this month so once again thanks
to everybody and have a great weekend
you